(gentle guitar music)
- We salute innovators who
push the limits of science,
changing how we see the
world and ourselves.
Growing up, Sally Ride read
about the space program
in the newspaper almost
every day and she thought
this was the coolest thing around.
- [Tam] The President
decided that Sally deserved
a Presidential Medal of Freedom.
- As the first American woman in space,
Sally didn't just break the
stratospheric glass ceiling,
she blasted through it.
- And Obama also decided
that I should be the one
to accept the award, which also was like,
"Oh my gosh, what is
going on in our world?"
Finally, you know?
Don't need to be secretive
about who I really am any more,
and I just wished that
Sally could experience
what I experienced.
- Tam O'Shaughnessy,
accepting on behalf of
her life partner, Dr. Sally K. Ride.
(applause)
- For the United States of America
I christen thee Sally Ride.
May God bless this ship
and all who sail in her.
(bottle crashes)
(applause and cheers)
The ship is just sort
of drop dead gorgeous.
So I'm happy and I also have to say that
when I see Sally's name
various places around the ship
my heart does something,
it's a weird feeling.
So it's happiness and a
little bit of sadness, too.
It still gets me, wow.
(cheerful music)
We both grew up in Southern California.
My memory is meeting Sally
in Redlands, California
when I was 12 and she was 13.
We were good friends during
the junior tennis days,
and both of us traveled
back East and of course
up and down California playing the
junior tennis tournaments.
Then Sally went off to
college, she was at Swarthmore
for about a year and a half and then
started to commit to physics,
and then went to Stanford.
I played on the circuit
for almost four years
and then when I left I went to
work in Northern California.
Sally was in school at
Stanford, so then we reconnected
and would go running in the Stanford hills
and play tennis in the morning before work
and that sort of thing.
I really wanted to study
biology, so I moved to Atlanta.
A few months later is when Sally was
eating scrambled eggs in
the Stanford Student Union
and looked at the student
newspaper and saw that
NASA was, for the first
time, recruiting women
to become astronauts.
- The moment I saw that
ad I knew that that's
what I wanted to do.
I ripped it out of the
newspaper and I literally
applied that afternoon.
It turned out a lot of other
people did the same thing.
(laughter)
There were about 8,000 of us who applied
to that opportunity, and
it was the first time
that they were admitting women
into the astronaut corps.
Out of that group, NASA
picked 35 of us to be
the first class of astronauts
specifically selected
for the space shuttle program.
- They called them the 35 new guys, TFNGs.
There were six women, the
very first women who were
kind of officially astronauts.
It was the class of 1978.
Everybody kind of trained
together and learned about
the space shuttle, all of its system.
When you're in space,
how everything works.
Then Sally got a really
key assignment which was
to help design and build the robotic arm.
So she got noticed there.
Then because of that she was named CAPCOM,
and the CAPCOM is the only person down in
Mission Control in Houston
that speaks to the astronauts.
- And we appreciate all
that, I think that gave us
a lot of good data.
- So it was a critical role, and Sally got
very high marks and got noticed for just
how cool she was under pressure,
how kind of concise she was
in speaking to the astronauts,
and relaying messages.
No one knows for sure how
the decision got made,
but the rumor is that she just
sort of did things so well,
and also she was very easy going.
So she was very easy
actually to get along with.
So all those things
turned into Sally being
the one named as the first American woman
to fly in space in 1982 sometime.
Then her crew worked
together for about a year
and then she flew in June
1983, her first flight.
- [Reporter] Now Dr. Ride,
during your training exercises
as a member of this group,
when there was a problem,
when there was a funny,
a glitch, or whatever,
how did you respond, how do
you take it as a human being?
Do you weep, what do you do?
- (laughs) Why doesn't anybody
as Rick those questions?
(crowd laughs)
(laughs)
I don't think that I react any differently
than anybody else on the crew does.
- [Reporter] Do you feel
that the coverage that
has been given has been disproportionate
with regards to the first
American woman in space?
- I think that it's maybe
too bad that our society
isn't further along and that
this is such a big deal.
But I guess if the
American public thinks that
it's a big deal then
it's probably good that
it's getting the coverage
that it's getting.
I think it's time that
we get away from that
and it's time that people realize that
women in this country can do
any job that they want to do.
- Every astronaut during
the space shuttle days
was allowed to invite
50 friends and family.
I didn't get to see Sally
'cause Sally was in quarantine,
but I got to experience the launch and
be in the stands with Sally's
mother and father and sister.
It was quite an experience.
- On launch day there
was so much excitement
and so much happening around us.
In the crew quarters, even
on the way to the launch pad,
going up the launch pad,
looking up and seeing
this huge rocket that kind
of sounds like an animal.
You can kind of hear the
gurgling and the hissing,
and it sounds like it's alive.
There's so much going on,
and of course it's all new.
The training really doesn't
prepare you for launch morning.
I spent an enormous amount of effort
just trying to stay focused.
- [Launch Control] T minus
10, nine, eight, seven, six,
we go for main engine start,
we have main engine start,
and ignition and liftoff.
Liftoff of STS-7 and America's
first woman astronaut
and the shuttle has pulled the tower.
- That was my first chance
to strap into a rocket
on the launch pad and
go from a standing start
to 17,500 miles an hour
in eight and a half
really fast minutes.
- When the rockets fire, Sally realized,
and all the astronauts know,
she couldn't control anything.
When the rocket fuel
ignites, it has to explode
and do what it's gonna
do until it burns out.
There is nothing to do.
- Once the space shuttle's engines cut off
and we were in orbit around Earth,
it's my first chance to unbuckle,
float weightless in the space shuttle.
Weightlessness, by the way, is something
that I recommend to all of you.
(crowd laughs)
It's just fun, there's
no other word for it.
Then of course it was also my first chance
to float over to the
window and take a look down
at the really spectacular
view of the Earth below.
- She saw this fuzzy thin
blue line and she was like,
and then she instantly realized that was
Earth's atmosphere, and it was a surprise
how little, how thin,
how fragile it looked.
That moment in space really made her
kind of a true environmentalist.
She just realized that our
atmosphere, Earth's air,
is all that protects
us from the blackness,
the vacuum of space and
whoa, we better protect it.
- [Controller] And
Challenger is back home,
back to Earth.
(crowd applauds)
- She flew her second
mission October of 1984,
and she was a seasoned
astronaut on that one.
Then she was assigned a third flight
and started training for that flight.
Then NASA sent her across the
country to give talks to kids
and corporate leaders
and teachers and so on.
So she started coming to Atlanta and
we resumed our friendship,
and then over time
it turned into something
else, it became romantic.
That was 1985.
So anyway, Sally was assigned her third
space shuttle flight, she came to visit me
from Houston in Atlanta for my birthday.
Then she was actually
flying home on January 28th
and the pilot told Sally
that the space shuttle
Challenger had exploded and
that all lives were lost.
They were her friends.
It was also the flight
with the first teacher
to fly in space, Christa McAuliffe.
So it was a national major
heartbreak and disaster.
Immediately after the space
shuttle Challenger blew up,
NASA stopped all operations,
'cause they needed to.
Ronald Reagan was our president.
He selected Sally to be
on the investigation team,
the Rogers Commission, to
figure out what went wrong
and to fix it, make sure
it never happened again.
And NASA decided to open
up an office of exploration
and headquarters in Washington D.C.
So once again Sally was
the one chosen to be
the first director, and
her experiences in space
and seeing the Earth from
above actually kind of
fed into the very first
report that she led
the study group and the analysis of,
it's called the Ride Report.
Then in the meantime she
realized it was gonna take NASA
a long time to kind of get going again.
Sally loved to fly, she
wanted to go in space,
she didn't really want
to just be an astronaut
on the ground doing other
work, important work,
but it didn't interest her.
So she decided to start
thinking about returning to
the university world as a professor.
And UCSD just said we'll
make you a full professor,
you'll have tenure,
and we expect you to do
good work in physics again.
And Sally was a California
girl and so she decided
UCSD was the perfect place for her.
I was back in the South and
I had started a PhD program
at University of Georgia in ecology.
But we had done a long
distance relationship
for four years, and it was
really hard on both of us.
So I joined Sally in 1989, the same year
she started at UCSD.
Sally had written one
children's science book
with her best friend from
high school, Sue Okie,
To Space and Back.
It's about the space shuttle
and how you go to space
and some of the physics and so on.
We decided that we wanted to try writing
children's science books together.
We just learned a lot
about how to write them,
how to choose the photographs,
how to think of the illustrations to help
young people learn the science,
and we just really enjoyed doing that.
By that time I was a
professor, she was a professor,
so we had kind of nine
to five jobs and then
we'd do it in the
evening or weekends also.
We started noticing the
articles and the reviews
about how American kids
do in math and science,
and we were just kind of appalled.
So in 2001 Sally and I
and three of our friends
started Sally Ride Science.
Our goal was put together
programs for kids
and teacher training for teachers,
and then also keep writing
books but on a bigger scale
that would be engaging,
exciting, but accurate
in all areas of biology,
chemistry, physics,
climate change, all the
topics across the board
that kids need to learn.
We started to bring in revenue through our
Sally Ride Science Festivals,
one-day events on college
campuses across the country.
Then we started publishing our books
and we just kind of kept boot strapping
everything we could, and
in March 2011 we were just
getting ready to launch
our big book series
with wonderful teacher guides and
teacher training and so on.
So we went to San
Francisco, we had a party to
announce our books.
Sally and I actually
took a cab to the party
and I noticed in the cab that Sally looked
a little yellow, and she had said earlier
she didn't want to eat
dinner, she didn't feel good.
So we flew back to San
Diego the next morning.
We took a cab from the
airport, dropped Sally off
at her doctor's office near UCSD.
I had the cab take me home, get the car,
come back to the doctor's
office, I parked the car,
and I'm getting out and walking
into the doctor's office
and Sally's coming out.
I can just tell by her face
that something's bad wrong.
And her doctor, Dr. Lopez, she said,
"Lopez says I have a mass in my pancreas
"and we're going right now
to radiology up the hill,
"UCSD Medical, to have a CAT scan."
And we were driving over kind of in a fog.
We were both just in shock.
I just remember thinking that oh my God,
our lives are gonna be different because
he said you have a mass,
and he also said that
it was very likely she
had pancreatic cancer.
So we heard the C word and
from the time she was diagnosed
until the day she died
it was like 17 months.
Shortly after Sally
died I'm in the office,
doing my work, learning
how to be a good CEO,
and my assistant comes over and says
you have a telephone call, and she said
it's the Secretary of the
Navy, Secretary Ray Mabus.
I said okay, well I'll take that call.
So I said hello to
Secretary Mabus and he said
the Navy was building two
brand new research vessels
and they were naming
one after Neil Armstrong
and they wanted to name the second one,
the other one, after Sally,
and what did I think of that?
And I just said wow, it's
a research vessel, right?
It's not a war ship?
'Cause she wouldn't like that.
And he said yes, and I
said that's fantastic.
Then he told me it was gonna
be operated by Scripps.
Then he said there's one
other thing I want to ask you,
would you be kind enough
to be the ship sponsor?
He explained that the
research vessel Sally Ride
is the first academic
research vessel ever named
after a woman.
So most ship sponsors
are the wives of the man
whose name is honoring the ship.
So he said, we think it's
appropriate as Sally's partner
for you to be the ship sponsor.
I was just kind of in shock,
I mean I was just kind of blown away.
It's like, wow, don't ask
don't tell really is history.
This is unbelievable.
Sally would have loved that moment.
And Sally would love that
this is a research vessel,
state-of-the-art, and
just would be so excited
about the research that's gonna be done in
the next 30, 40 years.
- A new ship like Sally Ride comes around
once every 40 years, so this
is a remarkably big deal
for people here at Scripps,
and I would say for Americans
and American scientists.
When we go to sea, we can
do any kind of science.
We can do geology, chemistry, physics,
atmospheric physics, we
study everything from
the very inside of the
Earth to up in the heavens.
So many of the things
that affect us on land
have their roots in the oceans,
from global climate change
to the fate of pollutants
to the food that we eat,
even the air that we breathe
relies on a healthy ocean.
We have to understand
what's going on out here.
Ships like Sally Ride make that possible.
- I love the new ship smell and all the
top-of-the-line equipment that we have.
It's also really exciting
that it's named after
Dr. Sally Ride, she is a great
legacy here in San Diego,
being a female scientist,
getting to go to space,
be an explorer.
I always wanted to be an explorer and
I still feel like a modern-day explorer
whenever I go out to sea.
- So Sally flew in space
when you were one year old.
- Yep, exactly, she was there.
- Sally loved science, she loved research.
That's what this vessel is all about is
pushing the envelope, trying
to learn more and more
about the oceans, about how
the atmosphere and oceans
interact and work together,
and she would love that.
But it's also about role
models and providing
more and more opportunities for girls,
for people of color, she loved all of that
and devoted her life to
it through our company
and many other things she did.
Then because she was a professor at UCSD
she was also the Director
of the California
Space Institute and she had an office
overlooking the Pacific at Scripps.
Then I think the final cool
piece is Margaret Leinen.
Margaret's a renowned oceanographer but
not very many women have been able to be
the head of Scripps
Institution of Oceanography.
So that's so cool, too.
It's just all of this coming
together, it's perfection.
(cheerful music)